Kobe Bryant's legendary mindset and work
ethic helped the NBA's third all-time
leading scorer win five NBA
championships and Olympic gold medal and
a guaranteed spot in basketballs Hall of
Fame it is also the same mindset that he
has taken into retirement so what is
this area so this is our our creative
area our creative space this is Kobe
Bryant's court now so we've created our
own term car analogy the creative space
at his production company granted he
Studios Kobe's next chapter launched in
2016 after 20 seasons in the NBA
is this something as a kid you thought
about that you would want to have that
food you know as a kid the main focus
was just playing the game and like my
last year and people asked me what I was
gonna do that's how I going the
storytelling they were like I there's
not a real job you know and I'm like
bets on his stuff deer basketball but
with his first project the animated
short film deer basketball I fell in
love with you
Kobe did what Kobe does stunned the
crowd not with a game winner but an
Oscar winner 5 seconds on the clock ball
in my hands yeah jumping into writing
and then win an Oscar right away well
you know it's funny
you look back I had a lot of practice on
road trips and on planes
writing writing writing no it's not
gonna let me restructure this let me
write this to let me know that you were
practicing a different craft while you
were playing your craft that's so many
no youthful yeah yeah and and you know
the structure of playing a game is
storytelling and when we sit down and we
watch basketball in act 1 act 2 act 3 I
mean all those acts are present
throughout the course of the game and as
you're managing a game you're managing
the ebbs and flows of it
momentum shifts right these are all
stories and so it's all the rules of the
world like basketball storytelling is a
passion for Kobe which began in high
school right around the time he was
winning a pennsylvania state hoops title
I had a great speaking arts teacher who
taught how to structure story how to
write story the world revolves around
storytelling and so it serves an
important role in our society at large I
get excited to try to you know play my
small partner hey everyone this is Kobe
Bryant and I'd like to introduce you to
the Pew knees under the granite umbrella
Kobe has helped shape stories from
podcasts to film all with the idea of
using sport and entertainment to educate
for our studio it's important to build
it where parents trust that your kids
can enjoy our content novels film series
otherwise and trust that they'll be
gaining valuable information from that
that's going to help them be better take
the trio of books Kobe's created for
young adults described by some as Harry
Potter meets the sports world The Wiz in
art series the first was basketball
based the wizard series training camp
and it hit number one on the New York
Times bestseller list where did the idea
for the wizard series come from it's
actually started from Mary Poppins the
Julie Andrews Julie Andrews reason man
there was a coach that was magical in
that way what would that look like Kobe
has created the fantasy world the books
are set in along with the characters and
their backstories he then plots out the
storylines before turning to a
hand-selected author in September Bryant
published legacy and the Queen about a
young female tennis player it was really
important for me in writing legacy to
understand those emotional frustrations
and the ebbs and flows of plans for it
so for inspiration well where do you
think he went so I called Serena on the
screen this is what I'm thinking
I obviously don't know nothing about
tennis so that you got to talk them
through and we sat on the phone for
about a good hour so talked about
challenges of playing a sport the
training aspect of it all the emotion
you started playing tennis later in life
yeah after you stopped playing
basketball yeah how good were you when
you first got out there
horrible mostly it was bad at us for oh
my god are you kidding yeah like I was
swinging a racket as if I was in a
homeroom
you know is you do what you know wrong
sport do you know I see guys know what
to do
as for the right sport remember I don't
want them to be able to breathe it's
still a part of Kobe's latest chapter
not as a player but the coach of his 13
year old daughter Gigi's basketball team
it's a lot of fun I mean she's really
driven very competitive and we have a
group of kids that love the game we're
gonna have an appetite to learn more and
so I enjoy being around them
you slow it down slow it down hit her
off you go
what's the biggest challenge in coaching
your own daughter making sure she knows
that I love her whether she plays well
or plays like crap it don't matter
you know you're my daughter before
you're a basketball player and it's
important that she knows that that's how
I feel and those aren't words you have
to behave that way you have to show her
that after a tough game you get in the
car and it's forgotten Kobe the dad is
admittedly a bit outnumbered at home he
and his wife Vanessa gave birth to their
fourth daughter in June this group of
six Kobe are the only guy yeah
they roll deep I get ganged up on quite
a bit but it's fine
in your house do they look at you and go
dad's just stop oh my god yeah I got
like I don't never know what I'm talking
about I have absolutely no say-so
and then they do a tongue-in-cheek but
it's but they mean it do you miss
basketball play do you miss playing
basketball I mean I guess so I guess so
like you know what if I'm shooting
around with my kids then yeah yeah from
that aspect of it
not enough to want to go out and play
that chapter has been written one of the
best to play the game of basketball
as for Kobe's full story fifty years
from now how do you want the world to
look at Kobe Bryant you know as a person
I was able to create stories that
inspired through children and families
to bond together and for the children to
dream and have the initiative to wake up
every morning and do all they can to
help that dream become a reality you
know that would be really really cool
and Bianca says it best I'm white
anyway to get buckets she goes yeah I'm
gonna get buckets like Gigi I'm get
buckets like Gigi because she just
doesn't know she has never seen me play
basketball
he never know like she's too little so
in her mind dad is just a person that
puts out stories so the basketball side
of you will be something for the the
older set if I'm doing everything right
that's what will happen